سيده تركيه نجت مع اطفالها الثلاثه من
الكارثه تبني لها حياه جديده في الشارع
اهمها الاول هو ان يتلقى اطفالها رعايه
واهتماما وبيئه حاضنه تجهلهم اكثر شجاعه
وقادرين على تحمل الصدمه
[تصفيق]
تعودنا مشاهده الزلازل والكوارث المماثله
على شاشه التلفزيون لم نتخيل ابدا اننا
سنمر بهذا يوما ما
لكل طفل قصه ومشهد صعب عاشوا تحت الانقاض
ليس من السهل محوه ولا تجاوزه الا بالدعم
النفسي المتخصص السيده لاي تحاول تقديم
هذا الدعم لافراد اسرتها وقد اصبحوا على
قارعه الطريق
فان
فسهم يقولون لا نريد ان نعيش هكذا اريد
غرفتي اريد العابي اريد ان اعيش في منزلي
ننجح في ايجاد طريقه
لتعزيتهم
قصه مؤثره اخرى في موقع مختلف في هاتاي
تقيم عائله نجم الدين دي ميرسي امام مبنى
منهار وقد وضعت صوره احد اطفالها
المفقودين على جذع شجره علها تجد من يتعرف
عليه
لم يعثر على اي اثر لاقارب حتى الان هناك
ثمانيه اشخاص بالداخل ولا توجد اخبار عنهم
على الاطلاق
هزه ارضيه امتدت ثواني معدوده وخلفت ماسيا
جمه حتى للناجين وحياه تحولت في غمضه عين
الى ازمات نفسيه كبيره قد تلازم بعضهم
طوال حياتهم انهم اليوم معرضون لما يعرف
برهاب زلازل